today on the matt walsh show there's an
update to the story of the black man who
assaulted a white macy's employee and uh
it's
it's outrageous so stick around for that
also five headlines including the
cancer-stricken two-year-old
who was stranded at a cancer center uh
while it was being attacked by rioters
in chicago
and in our daily cancellation we'll talk
about the feminists who who claim that
you know normal human interactions are
sexist microaggressions
so we've got to discuss that all of that
on the way and and more there's actually
a lot to cover today so bear with me
um but we'll we'll start with this if
you are in the unfortunate habit
of relying on the national media uh for
your
news and information you probably didn't
hear about the brutal assault of a white
macy's employee by a black man in june
the attack happened at the genesee
valley mall in michigan on june 15th
uh here it is if you haven't seen it
watch this
[Music]
don't touch me don't touch me don't
touch me
you quit touching me get them hurt
the assailant there is an
eighteen-year-old man named demir palmer
his brother filmed the attack reported
it to the media
which happily ran with the story
uncritical as always
reported that the employee had used a
used a racial slur
at the time the brother an alleged
rapper who goes by the name
ft quay said that they were innocently
shopping for a new shirt
when the employee in full hearing of the
two brothers referred to them
using the n-word um this is what the
brother told the new york post quoting
now from him he said
i just want people to know the real
story of what really happened
and what's in the description of me and
my brother just walking into macy's just
minding our own business
and yes we made a petty joke and asked
the guy was the shirt too little
when we uh when he could have asked me
he was just being funny and
just the fact of the remark that he said
that we all heard and just
what else were we supposed to do in this
age and time he didn't know what else to
do that was just
his instinct of course
uh it it shouldn't matter if the
employee said a bad word or not
that would in no way justify felony
assault
but it was obvious to anybody with two
brain cells rubbed together that the
story from the brothers was bogus um
and i said as much right away right
after this happened i said this
i guarantee you the word was not
actually said and indeed
what do you know it was bogus it was
made up it was a lie he never said the
n-word
but i'm getting ahead of myself a little
bit we'll get back to that in a second
all right
let's back up again remember this
happened on june 15th the local
prosecutor david leighton
did not file charges against damir
palmer until june 26th
that's over 10 days later it took 10
days to decide
that pummeling a man while he's crawling
on the ground begging for mercy
is in fact illegal um here's here's
leighton on june 26
announcing the charges listen to him he
shook up and he's
emotionally upset as well as physically
upset but he's emotionally upset
to think that you know anybody would
think he said
the alleged vile racial provoking slur
because he says he didn't say it and his
history suggests he didn't say it
we're charging a demire canal
palmer with a count of assault with
intent to do great bodily harm less than
murder
it's a felony assault charge punishable
by
up to 10 years in prison this was an
unprovoked attack
the internal video from macy's shows the
suspect approaching
from behind the victim the store manager
appears unaware that he's even there
the suspect then sucker punches him from
behind
knocks him to the floor continues to
punch him while he's on the floor
there is no evidence of provocation
whatsoever
um even if there were
verbal provocation which we have no
evidence of
violent retaliation is not permitted by
the law
vile racial provoking slur that's what
lightning is focused on
you see how in the context of announcing
charges against a man who committed a
barbarous assault against another human
he feels the need to begin by denouncing
a word that there's no reason to think
anyone even used
by the way no charges were filed against
the brother who filmed it
um of course okay so so fast forward two
months that was that was about two
months ago two months
forward and the obvious has now been
confirmed the racial slur
was not said it was a lie it was a hoax
yet again
but damir palmer blames his brother so
no honor among
thieves or in this case among people who
randomly assault retail employees
palmer said that his brother told him
the n-word was used
and that's what led to the assault now
here's where we get to the
inevitable and yet no less outrageous
part palmer's brother
still has not been charged with any
crime and palmer himself
is looking at quite possibly getting off
with probation
probation and not only probation but he
won't have a criminal record in this
scenario
this will be expunged from his record
like it never happened palmer
uh pleaded guilty to assault with intent
to do great bodily harm but the
assistant prosecutor patrick mccombs
says that he'll be sentenced under
something called the homes
uh youthful training trainee act the
home's youthful trainee
act now i had to google that and it took
me uh
to a website of tanis and schultz
michigan-based lawyers
here's what they tell us about the
holmes youthful training act it says
the homes use youthful trainee act more
commonly known as
hyta provides individuals between the
ages of 17 and 24 with a second chance
under the act
an individual charged with a crime may
petition the court for status as a
youthful trainee
the home's youthful trainiac states if
an individual pleads guilty to a
criminal offense
committed on or after the individual's
17th birthday but before his 24th
birthday
the court of record having jurisdiction
of the criminal fence may without
entering a judgment of conviction
and uh and with the consent of that
individual consider and assign that
individual to the status of youthful
trainee if the court grants the
individual's status under the home's
youthful training act he or she will be
placed on a probationary term
if he or she successfully completes the
probationary term the criminal
conviction
will not be entered into his or her
record the court will
dismiss all charges and his or her
criminal record will remain clean
okay dismiss all charges
that's where this is very likely headed
official sentencing is not until
september technically palmer could still
get 10 years in prison and at the
conclusion of that sentence
then his record is wiped clean but i
think we all know that's not going to
happen
the sentence can be anything from
probation to 10 years
and all signs are pointing to probation
here or something much closer to that
end of the spectrum
and then clean slate like magic like it
never happened
until it happens again which it will
because men who pummel other men for fun
don't just wake up one day as decent
human beings
that doesn't happen except maybe in
fairy tales
now according to the abc 12 report
a local affiliate in the town much of
the court
the court hearing over this case had to
do with the issue of the phantom n-word
and how upset that made poor damir
palmer reading from the ap reporter says
after pleading guilty to the 10-year
felony against him assault with intent
to do
great bodily harm less than murder
palmer
shared with the judge what led to the
assault inside the genesee valley mall
on june 15 2020
and then this is palmer now he says i
asked him a question about some clothes
palmer said i asked him about the jacket
type that i was about to get
palmer said the man answered him they
laughed
and then his brother told him the store
manager had called him the n-word
he admitted that he since learned his
brother lied to him
big shocker there um now we continue the
assistant prosecutor questioning the
brother says
why would your brother do that and he
says i i wouldn't know i honestly
wouldn't
palmer replied the assistant prosecutor
okay now listen to this part the
assistant prosecutor
told palmer he understands the anger
that would fuel the assault
but he said the store manager has asked
that the charge does not stay with
palmer forever
okay he understands he understands how a
person
might be so mad about a bad word that he
would beat another person senseless in
the middle of a macy's
he understands and yes the victim in
this case apparently has expressed his
consent to the lenient
sentence and that's the human shield
that the prosecutors are hiding behind
here by saying well it's what the victim
wants
but the fact that the victim who'd
already been attacked once
didn't want to come out and demand a
harsher sentence is completely
irrelevant here
we can think of many reasons why he
might express that point of view
even if it's not how he really feels all
right
so a lot a lot needs to be covered here
uh first of all once again
who gives the slightest damn whether he
said the bad word or not
it is in fact not understandable for an
adult to commit felony assault in
response to a word
not understandable at all the
implication from the way this sentencing
is working out is that felony assault is
legal or at least not very
illegal if a black man even so much as
believes
a racial slur was said i mean what if
the slur had been said what then
would they have simply let him walk no
questions asked not even probation
second and i'm sounding like a broken
record here but but but
you know we have another incident in
this case that if the races were
reversed
would be headline news the assailant
will be looking at hard time behind bars
on
federal charges hate crime charges now
i don't think that the hate crime
designation should exist at all i think
the whole category as a matter of law
is absurd but if we're gonna if we're
gonna have it then it ought to be evenly
applied
and this is a hate crime in fact damir
palmer admits as much
he told on himself in his excuse he
admits
that it's racially motivated think about
it he assaulted the store clerk because
the
because he thought that the clerk had
said a word now side note i don't
actually
believe him about this i don't think
that he thought that the word was used i
think that this was something both
brothers decided to do for fun
and for viral fame that's my theory but
in any event
going based on his testimony he
assaulted the macy's guy because he
thought
that the macy's guy had said a word we
could assume that demir palmer would not
have assaulted a black man for saying
that
in fact we know he wouldn't because he
himself uses the word
he's supposedly mad about the employee
allegedly using while he's assaulting
the employee
for using the word which he didn't
actually use if you're following me
in other words he assaults the employee
because the employee
is a white man who he thought
used a certain word he assaulted him for
being a white man using a certain word
this is not an argument that the word is
the same when used by white people as by
black people that's not my point
it's an argument that this assault was
undeniably motivated by the combination
of the alleged word
and the race of the person who said it
that is by definition a racially
motivated attack a hate crime
he should be going to federal prison for
this
but we know that everything is in two
tiers in this society
the media puts black on white assaults
and murder on one tier a low tier
white on black on another and the
justice system does the same
third point speaking of the justice
system
we see here the actual type of reform
that is necessary put aside all the
racial stuff and the double standard all
of that
think about this youthful trainee
nonsense the justice system in michigan
home to detroit one of the most violent
cities in america
considers adult violent criminals to be
trainees and will release them back into
society
without even any indication that they
are actually violent and dangerous
there's no there's no justice here
because there's no punishment
and they're failing to protect society
on two levels
first by releasing violent criminals
back into communities and then by
refusing to tell the communities that
these are violent criminals
so a law like this fails in every
conceivable way
to ensure that the justice system does
what it's supposed to do
you know we don't have a large-scale
problem in this country of the justice
system
system coming down too hard on the bad
guys there may be there's some examples
of that sure but there are many many
many more examples
of the justice system putting on you
know its kids kid gloves and slapping
violent dangerous people on the wrist
and then patting them on the head and
sending them on their way practically
inviting them to continue committing
crimes
until they've finally done something so
heinous that even the most lenient and
hen-pecked prosecutor has no choice but
to take the book
and throw it at them rather than doing
what they normally do which is to take
the book
and throw it out allowing criminals to
continue
along in their criminal ways the streets
of our cities are overrun
by dangerous violent people who are
known to the system
known to be dangerous and violent and
yet are permitted to stay out on the
street
free unencumbered and the story often
has a predictable infuriating and tragic
ending and something tells me that the
story of damir palmer
very may have the same sort of ending
let's go to five headlines
[Music]
you know there are a lot of occasions
where you might need a nice watch
whether you're going on a date
uh you're going out for an interview
you're going for a wedding a night out
whatever it is
um that's an occasion where you might
want to class it up
and actually have a nice watch and big
sale alert from our favorite sponsors
uh you already know how i feel about
ventura watches i've been telling you
about them for
for months a long time long time sponsor
on the show seriously watches that are
stunning and well under 200
okay it's incredible how much these
timepieces stand out and
just how good you feel when you wear
them bincher watches is dedicated to the
craft they put the time and effort into
crafting timepieces
so you can wear them day after day
extremely durable
as well like i said i've had these
watches for a long time i can tell you
um
they they they're they're durable also
right now vincero is running a site-wide
sale to celebrate their sixth
anniversary this will uh
not only be the biggest sale of the year
but the biggest sale in manchero history
up to 30
off site-wide no code required your
discount will be automatically applied
to checkout when you visit
slash vincerowatches.com 30 off site
wide okay everything on site is on sale
no exclusions including all four of
their all new collections
all of that is available um now with
ventura watches
there's no brand name market you know
markup that is no big time price tags
their promise to you is very simple
solid well-made products
uh that you will enjoy wearing these
guys know just how important it is to
shop from brands you can trust go shop
their anniversary sale right now vincero
watches
you know i've been wearing my ventura
watch for a long time um i love the
watch
makes me feel classy when i wear it
which i need a lot of help with the
classy
in the class i mean as you can tell from
the way that i normally dress
flannels and everything usually dress
like a lumberjack but but
uh which of course nothing wrong with
that but then i put the watch on feel a
little bit more classy and you know what
else i like when someone asks me the
time
i can do this rather than having to pull
my my phone out
and i i just i just enjoy it it feels
very it feels very old school so
continue supporting this brand as they
continue to support the matt wall show
go to
shop vincero sixth anniversary sale the
deal is really too good to pass up go to
v-i-n-c-e-r-o watches dot com forward
slash walsh
vincero watches forward slash walsh
all right let me tell you about um
two-year-old owen buell and you could
see him right there
uh owen has cancer stage four
neuroblastoma
owen along with his family has been
staying at the ronald mcdonald house
near laurie children's hospital in
chicago
ronald mcdonald house was targeted by
looters and rioters during the riots a
few days ago
yes a place with cancer-stricken
children
was attacked the the glass was shattered
door was shattered
to make matters worse owen was supposed
to go home to have his birthday party
and he just he just turned two this
little guy has earned his birthday party
more than
than than certainly i've ever earned in
a birthday party um
and he apparently is a big fan of llamas
who isn't i'm a big fan of llamas too
and so
his mom had a big three foot tall
stuffed llama
shipped to the house as part of the
birthday celebration she was looking
forward to bringing him home so you can
see that
um but the party had to be canceled
because of
the riots they couldn't discharge any
children in the middle of this
so owen missed his birthday party
meanwhile
as owen's mother describes it they could
hear just imagine
these children they could hear the
noises they could hear the the sirens
and the gunshots and everything and all
the chaos
and while they're trapped at this place
imagine the fear and the terror for
these kids who are already going through
something
that no kid should have to endure so
if you need another reason to despise
the rioters
and blm here it is just
reprehensible awful self-obsessed people
who don't give the slightest damn
about anyone but themselves remember
something yeah remember remember we
played this yesterday the blm activists
in chicago justifying looting by saying
that they should be able to take
whatever they want because they're
entitled to it let's play that again
i don't care if somebody decides to loot
a gucci
or a macy's or a nike because that makes
sure that that person eats
that makes sure that that person has
clothes that makes sure that that person
can make some kind of money because this
city obviously doesn't care about them
not only that that's reparations that is
reparations
anything they want to take take it
because these businesses have insurance
they're going to get their money back my
people aren't getting anything
so blm has taken whatever they want
because they're entitled to it
while cancer-stricken toddlers are
deprived
of their birthday parties because
it is a direct correlation because blm
had to take what it what it is owed
apparently
um that meant that cancer-stricken
toddlers out of luck
by the way positive note here if you go
to my twitter right now i've got a link
up to the gofundme for
owen and uh uh it's it's a gofundme for
you know for of course his medical
expenses and and whatever else the
family
needs the money for and so you can go
there if you have it in if you're if
you're able to donate then do that we
i you know someone sent me the gofundme
page yesterday it had raised twenty
thousand dollars
uh when they sent it to me uh since
february
and then i put it up and we all kind of
rallied together and overnight
we doubled it to for another twenty
thousand um so
go go to my twitter uh if if you can and
donate there all right
the ma the manager of a bakery in
chinatown was trying to talk to uh mayor
bill de blasio about how the shutdowns
and the coveted policies are have
affected
have destroyed his business and he's
getting quite emotional
in this clip understandably but let's
look at de blasio's response to him
watch
we've been taking a hit since january
we lost our chinese new year our busiest
day
of our community the most festive
holiday that
he just doesn't care at all speaking of
self-obsessed
not giving the slightest damn about ever
anybody but yourself there's
there's de blasio i mean de blasio the
rioters blm antifa
these are all match matches made in well
not heaven but in the other direction
anyway
um they're all they're all sort of peas
in a pod very very similar in that way
he just he doesn't care at all this
guy's
this guy you know this this this
business owner
life business destroyed de blasio
couldn't couldn't possibly care less
just walks away from him
number three an article in the la times
uh here's the headline says want more
diversity in camping
start with the gear and the article goes
into
detail talking about how fewer black
people go camping
and this you guessed it is due to
historical injustice and racism
you know all those laws on the books
forbidding black people from camping
it's
well you have to admit those laws would
be pretty bad if they existed
now i i and let me say i am totally
against those non-existent laws
i those laws don't exist and i say they
should continue not existing
now as for the question in the headline
i just thought i know it's a rhetorical
question i thought i'd answer it anyway
want more diversity in camping allow me
to answer that question no
i don't actually i don't want more
diversity in camping i also don't want i
don't i don't not want more diversity in
camping i don't want more i don't not
want more
i just have no feeling at all about the
racial makeup of the camping community
doesn't matter to me at all shouldn't
matter to anyone people will camp if
they want to
uh if they don't want to camp they won't
if more white people than black people
want to go camping
okay why would that matter
why does every single facet of society
need to
have a certain predetermined fill a
certain quota
or a racial diversity quota who cares
this something like camping as with so
many other things in in
society it really comes down to do
people want to do it or not
it's like that with the sexism claims
and we'll talk about more about this in
a second
but we look at certain industries and we
say well there's not enough women doing
this job
have you ever thought that maybe there's
not more women doing the job because
women don't want to do that job
you know there's there's a lot of uh
there's not a lot of gender diversity
in the roofing industry okay most
roofers on a hot roof in july
almost all of them men in fact i don't
think i've ever seen a female roofer
maybe a few of them exist
is that because females are excluded
from root from from roofing no it's just
because
they don't want to do it and so they
don't uh i suspect there's
something similar going on with camping
all right number four
huge news here finally we'll get to
something important farmers in botswana
have
come up with a uh an incredible
innovation they figured out that you can
prevent predators lions leopards etc
from attacking your cows if you draw
eyes on the cow's
butt and you can see right here
eyes on the butt and they don't have to
be very realistic eyes either apparently
even these lackadaisical eyes will work
why do they work well
uh they've done a whole study to figure
out why this works i can tell you why it
works
would you want to eat a hamburger with
with eyes on it if you picked up your
hamburger
at applebee's and there's and there are
eyes staring at you would you eat it
i mean i still would because i'm hungry
but it freaked me out no question
uh all i can say is that this so far
though is a massive missed opportunity
if these if these farmers are drawing
eyes
i know you probably thought the same
thing as me right we're putting eyes on
the cow's butt okay i'm with you there
sounds good why aren't we putting googly
eyes
go to joanne fabrics if they have that
in botswana
get the googly eyes put that on the butt
of the cow
more realistic a lot funnier
let's go number five finally a new study
says that a certain mind-controlling
fungus can infect cicadas and turn them
into zombies
and to be honest with you i'm really
just mentioning the story uh as an
excuse to transition into a story about
my kids this that's the only reason so
we're putting that to the side enough
about the cicadas
uh i thought this was pretty great and i
don't have anywhere else to put in the
show so i'm just going to tell you here
i uh yesterday was out of the house our
our three-year-old
son got mad at his brother uh because
uh he wouldn't play with toys with him
so our three-year-old took one of the
toys
plastic shark threw it at his older
brother
hit him in the eye actually ended up
giving him a nice little cut beneath the
eye like right here
um and i guess my my younger son's logic
was listen if you don't want to play
with the toys with me
then i will beat you with them that was
his logic now
he got punished for that of course but
when i got home i decided that i should
have a a talk with him about it
and i was talking to him about it and i
asked him
why he did it even though i knew the
answer but i asked him anyway
and he told me this was his excuse all
right he told me
that he was worried that his older
brother might be a zombie
so he threw the toy at him that's what
he said
and you know i i didn't expect his
excuse to be persuasive i knew he'd have
some excuse
i didn't expect it to be so persuasive
but i heard that and i thought
all right fair who
i mean who can what do you want him to
do he he thought his brother was a
zombie
or not even that see what i liked about
it was it wasn't he didn't come out and
and outright accuse his brother being a
zombie he said
might be so so it was it was more like
a plausible theory that he couldn't rule
out
without further investigation and the
investigation involved
throwing a plastic shark at his eye i
don't totally understand the connection
there to be honest with you
but i don't have any experience battling
zombies do you so i don't think that we
can really pass any judgment there
and i thought that was that was good
kids will always kids are always coming
up with
it's one of the great joys of being a
parent is listening to all the
excuses from your kids i use the word
joy there are other descriptions you
could probably use but
i'm going with joy for right now all
right we're going to get to our daily
cancellation in just one second i want
to tell you about our most exclusive
membership tier over daily wire which is
all
access all access members get to
join all access live which is our
exclusive live stream q and a's hosted
every night by each of the hosts
including myself
all access memberships also include
exclusive access to live online
discussions with our host
writers and special guests you also get
not one but two leftist tiers tumblers
with your membership as well as early
and sometimes exclusive access to new
daily wire products
which you saw last week we had the the
bats the limited
collector's edition baseball bat those
went out those were gone in 48 hours so
you want to get
signed up dailywire.comwalls right now
to get 20
off all access with coupon code access
that's dailywire.com
coupon code access to get 20 off your
membership today for our daily
cancellation i will be canceling women
uh not all women don't worry in fact if
you are
a woman i hope that you do not fall into
the category being canceled this
afternoon i am canceling
women who have a tendency to claim that
relatively normal yet uncomfortable or
irritating social interactions are
sexist
now i suppose i could simplify by saying
i'm canceling feminists but i think that
there may be some women who don't
identify as feminists and yet still fall
into this trap
so now look i'm not talking here about
things words behaviors
that are actually abusive or degrading
to women in fact just this week
we've discussed the latest cardi b song
which is intensely degrading and
dehumanizing to women
um yes it was a woman who produced it
but even so it amounts to an attack on
the dignity of women
and there's plenty of this sort of thing
in the culture and if you're a woman who
has spoken out about that
god bless you to you i say girl power i
will i will join you at the protest
march for that
that's not what i'm talking about what
i'm referring to here are as i said
the more ordinary everyday social
interaction based
sexism claims if you want examples of
this kind of thing just go to google and
type in
sexist microaggressions or everyday
sexism or similar keywords
you'll be greeted with volumes and
volumes just like this one random
example from yahoo finance finance
um this is just you know one one article
a pop-tab of many
and the headline why sexist
microaggressions are holding women back
at work
so just reading a little bit of this it
says around 64 of women are supposed to
exposed to this kind of discrimination
according to the report with black and
lesbian women facing an even greater
variety of microaggressions in the
workplace
uh and then it con continues so what are
examples of microaggressions experienced
by women
that's a very good question according to
the women in the workplace report the
most common issue is women having to
provide more evidence of their
competence than men and they are more
likely to have their judgment questioned
even on things that they're an expert in
um
and then the article goes into you know
anecdotes from various women
here's one it says one asian woman who
had worked four years at a company told
the report
authors of her experience of a
microaggression she said i was in an
elevator
press the button for the executive
office someone said to me um no honey
that's for the executive offices
the interns are going to this floor
that's not funny but i
another middle eastern woman the vice
president of a company added i walked
into a meeting where i was the only
woman in a very large room of men
and when i sat down an older white man
from another company turned to me
out of nowhere and said could you take
notes for the meeting
which was a little bit odd because i was
the lawyer
in the room uh the one doing the
negotiating
okay so those and then it goes into
other anecdotes and so on and so forth
um and then it's it stipulates
importantly microaggressions can be hard
to pinpoint they might be brief comments
or small actions such as interrupting or
talking over someone in a meeting
no matter what form they come in
microaggressions can have a serious
impact and create a toxic working
environment that might seem innocuous
but over time these incidents and
comments can lead to self-esteem
or rather to low self-esteem feelings of
alienation and impact
on mental health all right so a few
classic examples there of alleged
micro sexism uh that you find
there are other classics that you've no
doubt heard being told to smile is one
women will sometimes complain that
others remark on their lack of smiling
and and they'll chalk that up to sexism
of course there's the old favorite
mansplaining and mansplaining is any
time a man
explains something in a condescending or
patronizing way i'm doing
man's planning right now in fact
unwelcome advice
a cousin of mansplaining is another
example so questioning of judgment
interrupting talking over talking to a
telling a woman to smile explaining
things dulling out advice unwelcome
touching unwelcome flirting
all of these are commonly considered
sexism and they're used to promote this
this this narrative of a
of a patriarchal and male privileged
society
but it's all bogus
almost entirely bogus might there be
some occasions where a man interrupts or
explains or
says you should smile more because he
has a low opinion of women
sure i suppose so i can't see inside
anybody's mind i don't know
what i do know is this that all of these
things all that i just listed
all of these supposed sexist anti-woman
aggressions however micro they may be
happen to men all the time all the
time none of this is unique to women nor
is there any credible reason to assume
that they ex that they're experienced
more often by women
all we know and save yourself the
trouble of sending me links to studies
look at the studies the studies say the
studies have declared
all we know is that women more often
report and remember these incidents and
interpret them as sexism
what we do not know is that women
actually experience
these events more often and i submit
that there's no good reason to assume
they do
now this is all anecdotal of course but
that i mean all of this is the claims
from feminists are anecdotal it's all
anecdotal so let me add my own anecdote
okay
i am told to smile all the time
i have just never cared enough to make
note of it or
or of any specific incident and to store
it away in my head as a traumatic sex
experience
sex is experience because ultimately i
don't care what other people think of my
demeanor or my personality
a lot of people hate me and hate my
demeanor and personality fine
doesn't matter to me your opinion of me
is irrelevant
i don't care what about being talked
over what about being interrupted
condescended to
men experience that all the time all of
that
though men who who learn to assert
themselves will experience it less but
that's true for women too the point is
that
if you have a more submissive
personality
you're more likely to be ignored or
overridden especially in a work
environment
in a competitive environment that's not
an anti-woman thing that's a that's a
human society thing like it or not
what about unwelcome advice are you
kidding me i would wager here that 95
percent of all the unwelcome advice
given in a day across the world
cumulatively is supplied by women
now this is partly a positive reflection
of women though women give advice
nag we used to call it for the same
reason that they gossip it's it's the
downside of the more positive attributes
more common in women
of sensitivity and empathy women are
more likely to care what other people
are doing thinking saying and feeling
yes this can lead them to gossip it can
lead them to nag but can also lead them
to be wonderfully caring and invested in
other people
and uh you know and very empathetic now
men
we're less likely to care all that much
about what other people do
the plus side is that we don't nag very
often we're less prone to gossip
but the negative side is that we can
sometimes lack sensitivity we can lack
empathy we can perhaps
err on the side of indifference more
often than we should
um this is a difference between the
sexes and one of the reasons why our
differences are complementary and one of
the reasons why it's so great to have a
mom and dad in the home to balance each
other out you need
sort of both sides of this but the point
here is that
is is simply that because of the
masculine and feminine tendencies just
described
some of this everyday sexism is far more
likely to come
from women so why does it
seem like women experience these things
more how could it be possible that
somehow men have been become known in
modern society as the nagging busybodies
while women are suddenly the aggrieved
and frustrated victims of this behavior
it's it's it's absurd well i think it
has a lot to do with
another difference between men and women
men only articulate about 10 percent of
their emotions and experience
for women the number is closer to 225
percent
these are not scientific figures i admit
but the point is that
uh men don't talk as much about what
they're feeling and going through
and are especially unlikely to go home
and tell their wives elaborate stories
about
you know being interrupted at a meeting
or being told to smile and how
how upset it made them not because it
doesn't happen but because for one thing
a man might feel embarrassed that he was
emasculated and therefore
be more likely if anything to tell a
story about some other incident in the
day
when he was assertive and in control
just to assuage his bruised ego
also he won't bring it up because men
are more practical
even about emotional matters and
admittedly to a fault sometimes so a man
will
calculate in his mind whether the story
about his day is actually useful or
relevant to anyone
and if he decides that it isn't he won't
say it
women don't perform those calculations
as often
for better or worse um
now that's where the confusion comes
from
it is like so much of the confusion
between the sexes a matter of
miscommunication or lack of
communication
and now i'm starting to sound like my
wife who for the record has never in her
life
said the phrase microaggression or even
sexism unironically i don't think i've
ever heard her call anything sexist ever
which is awesome and so this time she is
not
the one being canceled but a bunch of
other women are i'm afraid
being canceled which i'm sure they will
hasten to say
is sexist on my part so be it
the cancellation stance and we'll leave
it there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there